they're trying to play tough i mean uh
push our guys around and talk but uh
we we can do that too uh and we show
them
as soon as they came back here that we
can push guys around too
we can talk as well so what you're gonna
do about it game four you're coming back
again
well it's gonna happen again win the
game we talk and we push around so what
are you gonna do about it we can't be
physical but we can
win games as well and now we're coming
to your home
to win this game again to send you on
vacation just heard about it i do not
care
and we're not focused on it we focus on
what we got to do as a team so
i'm going to ask what we got to do uh
that's great but
you know why would i give a hell what
clinton fellas to say i'm 32 years old
bro i
i never talked like that in my life and
i'm not going to start now when
clint capela's like start talking crazy
it don't get to me like that so i'm just
too old for that
i love this man does that qualify as
poking the bear or i love
poking or nudging the sleeping uh you
know
the man said he'd come to you the man
said he'd come into your house and go in
your season
i know i love that i'm coming to your
house and seeing you on vacation
that's so disrespectful i wouldn't call
a poke and a bear like
you know some teams have that weird real
really tough attitude
and then when you put it to them and
they start whining and complaining i
don't
poke the bear now now when you poke the
bear
make sure you perform make sure you get
all the rebounds you catch all the love
and make sure you play i mean listen
we've we've all talked trash in
basketball like you know
some some people don't get going until
they talk draymond kg like they have to
talk to like get them going this is
this is fun for me listen everybody
gonna be watching that game i'm just
proud of trey because he's
he's growing up last couple years he was
a steph curry want to be and he's
just jack jack jack now he's controlling
the game no controlling the pace he's
getting foul you know he's not getting
caught up in the you know bs
of it he's playing excellent ball so
good luck to the hawks
teams up 3-1 like the hawks win 95
percent uh